congressman jim jordan has one of the
toughest jobs in all of washington
he's the ranking member on the house
judiciary committee
which means he's in the minority having
to fight off some of the house democrats
most
liberal ideas but jim jordan is no
stranger to fights
he was put on the intelligence committee
during the democrats first
impeachment push he's been on the house
oversight committee
for over a decade
investigating some of congress's most
important significant investigations and
incidentally
incidentally it was also an ncaa
wrestling champion
so he is not afraid to mix it up a
little bit
welcome to you ranking member jordan
good to be with you trey i think it's
the first time i've got a chance to be
on when you were hosting so uh
congratulations
good good to be with you well thank you
it is always good to see you
i meant what i said you are a fighter
but you're in the minority right now
what are you fighting against on the
judiciary committee what are they up to
well they're not up to much in the
committee trade because i mean you you
served on that committee and oversight
and a host of others too so you know
what it's like and then normally you
have hearings
jerry nadler now two months into this
new congress is yet to have a full
committee hearing other than the
organizational meeting
so we're not really up to much they're
bringing these bills straight to the
floor
and they're they're attacking americans
freedoms i mean you think about
trey in the last year democrats in
government have told americans you
couldn't go to church he couldn't go to
work he couldn't go to school
democrats in government said it was fine
for them to go to a five-star restaurant
hang out with their friends and their
lobbyists but we couldn't be with our
family for thanksgiving
and now this week they're coming after
your second amendment liberties with two
pieces of legislation
that severely limit your second
amendment your right to own a firearm to
protect yourself and your family
so this is just the typical democrats we
see today it's a constant attack on your
first amendment rights with the canceled
culture
and what they've done with cobot and now
an attack on your second amendment
liberties as well
so they just passed hr one and what
you're saying is they bypassed the
judicial
judiciary committee they went straight
to the house floor yep yep
with that bill the host i mean last week
they radically changed election law
didn't bring the bill to committee they
radically changed police law didn't
bring that bill through committee
this week they're getting radically uh
going to change radically uh change gun
law
and then next week they're gonna change
immigration law and add to the mess that
the biden administration
has created on the border in just 47
days so when we talk about i know you
had senator scott on earlier and you
talked about all the crazy things
in the covenant relief bill the
so-called coveted relief bill it is
truly
unbelievable what they are up to and the
radical changes they are making
in so many public policy areas and i
think as tim said earlier
we just got to block and tackle and do
everything we can
to hold them off so that we can win back
the house in a year and a half kevin
mccarthy will be speaker
and then we get ready to win back the
white house in 2024.
well jimmy i i know you read the bill
because you read them all before you
voted on them h.r went
in didn't come before your committee but
what are some of the things in hr1 that
the viewers should be most alarmed at
it's headed to the senate now right
yeah well if it passes this will
radically change it'll put in place
codify
the crazy changes they made in the
run-up to the 2020 election
in these key states it'll now make that
a federal policy across the country
mail-in ballots ballot harvesting and
then when it's all done they want you
the taxpayer the taxpayers to pay for it
i mean such a deal i don't think the
folks you had the privilege of
representing in south carolina
the folks i get the privilege of
representing in west central ohio
i don't think they really want to pay to
get jerry nadler and nancy pelosi and
chuck schumer reelected heck they
probably didn't even want to pay to get
you and i re-elected they would rather
us do that on our own but this bill
makes radical changes to our election
law takes it away from the states
federalizes that and then requires the
taxpayer ask the taxpayers to then
pay for campaigns so that's how crazy it
is that's why we got to keep
pushing back i hope and i think mitch
mcconnell and the republican the senate
we're going to be able to stop this
let's certainly hope that they do
jimmy let me ask you one more question
before i let you go is it still true
that michael cohen has testified before
congress more recently than michael
horowitz who is the inspector general
for the department of justice
you may be right i'm looking forward to
getting the justice department up here
when we whenever we get an attorney
general and i'd love to get uh
i'd love to get the fbi director here in
front of our committee if we ever have a
hearing
well i can't think of anybody better to
be in the position of fighting even
though we're in the minority
2022 is coming thank you ranking member
jordan my best to you and your family